et justement cette nomination
d'elizabeth band ça fait la une de la
presse en france et pas seulement
c'est l'heure de la revue de presse
évidemment avec hélène frade bonjour
hélène bonjour dame ya donc de nombreux
journaux auront choisi donc elisabeth
borne pour l'heure une avec la
nomination donc d'elisabeth borne aux
portes de au poste le premier ministre
hier la nomination d'une femme à
matignon la deuxième à diriger le
gouvernement trente ans après edith
cresson
enthousiasme le parisien aujourd'hui en
france c'était le point d'exclamation le
journal évoque un symbole fort la
correction d'une anomalie française
alors que la plupart des pays du monde
sont indifféremment dirigées par des
femmes ou des hommes le quotidien cite
la finlande la suède le danemark la
lituanie ou encore l'estonie dont les
gouvernements sont dirigées par des
femmes mais aussi les instances
européennes avec pour seul afin d'aller
à la tête de la commission et roberta
mais de cela au parlement une femme à
matignon les échos se trouve étrange que
cela soit que cela soit encore j'en
perds mon latin un événement en 2022
alors qu'angela merkel a été chancelière
pendant 16 ans et que theresa may a
occupé le 10 downing street après
margaret thatcher pour le journal la
discrimination positive dont aurait
bénéficié elisabeth elisabeth board
serait secondaire car personne ne peut
mettre en cause ses compétences je cite
une bonne connaisseuse des enjeux
environnementaux
réputé autant pour sa capuche sa
capacité de travail que pour sa rigueur
en 2022 le véritable événement serait
que cela n'en soit pas en ou pour le
dire autrement que nous admettions
qu'elisabeth borne a été nommé
uniquement pour ses qualités
professionnelles et politiques commente
également le quotidien la croix mais
cette nomination d'elizabeth bande elle
est perçue par la droite comme un signe
envoyé par emmanuel macron à la gauche
l'opinion relève que contrairement à ses
deux prédécesseurs elisabeth borne est
issu de la gauche de la gauche de la
macro ni en tout cas qui auraient été
ultra mobilisés pour torpiller la
candidature d'une femme issue de la
droite ou du centre
elisabeth bornes corps trop dans le
dessein de cas qu en compagnie de
jean-luc mélenchon le patron des
insoumis ans le 16 paires l'emporter aux
législatives du mois prochain et se
retrouve à matignon et il ironie c'est
sympa d'assurer l'intérim jusqu'aux
législatives
elisabeth bornes une techno jamais élu
issu de la gauche le figaro revient lui
aussi sur la levée de boucliers au sein
de la majorité pour contre le choix
éventuel de l'ancien ministre de jacques
chirac qui a traîné vautrin un épisode
qui aura accréditerait l'idée qu
emmanuel macron aura été contraint de
revoir ses plans in extremis et
donnerait la regrettable impressions je
cite d'un choix par défaut et alors à
gauche cette nomination d'elizabeth
bordel est perçue comme un nouveau signe
envoyé à la droite et de jean castex à
elisabeth bornes du pareil à la même
libération considère l'arrivée à
matignon de l'ex ministre des transports
comme un événement politique au sens où
elle ne signe aucune rupture avec le
quinquennat précédent ni sur le plan
écologique ni sur le plan social
emmanuel macron en a manifestement fini
avec le disruptif analyse libé qui
voient toutefois dans le profil dit
techno d'elisabeth bornes impossible
avantage pour la fonction de chargé de
la planification écologique la nouvelle
locataire de matignon ou connaissant par
coeur l'appareil d'état et donc son
inertie potentiel l'ancien ministre des
transports à l'origine des réformes de
la réforme de la sncf a également
réformer l'assurance chômage en tant que
ministre du travail des faits d'armes
qui lui valent on le voit l'hostilité de
l'humanité la caisse sociale à matignon
prédit le journal on prend les mêmes et
on recommence lui m'a dit ne pas
attendre de surprise à l'issue de ce jeu
de chaises musicales au sein de
l'exécutif voilà pour ce tour d'horizon
de la presse française qu'est ce qu'on
en dit à l'étranger à l'image de
gardienne damian la presse étrangère
souligne que cette nomination d'une
femme à matignon est une première donc
depuis 30 ans le temps se réjouit
d'ailleurs de voir enfin apparaître une
fissure dans le plafond de verre
français et note que la france reste en
retard sur la parité au plus haut sommet
de l'état alors qu'elle est considérée
progressiste dans le monde du travail le
quotidien suisse site l'ancienne
première ministre edith cresson ce n'est
pas le pays qui est machiste c'est sa
classe politique le soir est beaucoup
plus critique pas de grands pas en avant
ni de moment historique il y a surtout
un président qui souhaite tenir le
gouvernail du pouvoir entre ses seules
ma avec à ses côtés imparfaite exécutant
fidèle loyal pour le quotidien belge vue
de la cause féminine il s'agirait même
presque d'une caricature à notre époque
désigner une femme un poste de premier
plan pour y être instrumentalisée hante
un très mauvais service au combat contre
le fameux plafond de verre scinde le
journal la presse étrangère est
également partagée sur le sens du
message politique envoyé par emmanuel de
new york times qui présentait lisabeth
mâcon que elisabeth bornes vus lexus
soit mal de laxiste comme une adepte du
profil bas voit dans sa nomination une
main tendue par emmanuel macron aux
électeurs de gauche dont le soutien lui
sera nécessaire pour contrôler la future
assemblée nationale de times par le plus
tôt lui d'une recherche d'unité de la
part du chef de l'état dont le journal
décrypte ainsi la future répartition des
tâches avec elisabeth borne à laquelle
échoit le rôle ingrat je cite de premier
ministre une spécificité spécificité
bien française selon le quotidien
britannique quand les choses vont bien
le président reçoit les applaudissements
et lorsqu'elle tourne mal le premier
ministre en assume la responsabilité
permettant ainsi au chef de l'état de
prendre de la hauteur bref de rester
jupiter fusible vous avez dit merci
beaucoup et une phrase en substance en
tout cas ce que dit le times je me
permettrai pas d' émettre de jugement
merci hélène on se retrouve un peu plus
tard